Thank
you Yamacho It's not a supplementary class day Noto It's
a good memory
I've been doing tempering all
the time Even though I've never made a mistake when I was in elementary school Saki-cho Hurry up and decorate it I thought it wouldn't suit you today too It
suits you well
Nagae Kurdish place nerv The
previous one is everyone who says it's silly
This is special
[Music]
] For Yamato
Mt. Yamato
Iko I've grown a lot
now I'm taking a bath with a sugar chain I'll do it again next
time Come anytime
Image king
Warigatoyama, etc.
[Music]
Thank you for giving me the favorite chocolate
All-prevention
Dangerous,
I'm image king me nice nice
bea
me me Thank you for liking Taki
Yakukai tasker Pink
I want you
teru favorite
cho will reach 2nd place ah ah ah